good morning everybody welcome back how
you doing happy Monday welcome to
another episode of the gratitude journal
live stream episode number what number
we at number 41 I love it we share three
things that were grateful for I'm going
to share three things that I am gonna
before you guys going to share yours in
the live chat I'm gonna give some
shoutouts and then visit you watching us
words leave it in the comments below I
think it's really important but you guys
have been joining me for the past 41
days then hopefully you've seen that
benefit that increased awareness that
increased happiness that you can then
pour into your business I think it's
important that you do it consistently I
do this because I've noticed a big
change in my life doing it as well as
people around me who are doing it and so
hopefully we can bring this out to
believe nation and you guys are feeling
happier more confident more productive
during the day so consistency is
important and then also again ask
yourself why remembering why it's
important not just listening through
things off but feeling it right you
gotta be able to feel it if you want to
make that emotional connection so I'm
going to kick us off three things that
I'm grateful for for the day i'm going
to start number one with risk-taking
I've taken a number of risks over the
past couple weeks that I've talked about
it but the one that comes to mind is on
the weekend this I don't remind my my
sister and Alex decided to jump out of
an airplane and they're both afraid of
heights and decided to do this thing
together this crazy thing together and
jumped out of an airplane so saucing
with the footage of their faces and
cheeks you know flapping and going crazy
and and when I spoke to my sister but as
she was saying that you know in all of
the first few seconds we're at to that
scary and then it was just calm and
peaceful and beautiful and it's funny
how we're afraid of these big things
right
the things that we're afraid of that
actually we don't really have a reason
to be afraid of and so I'm super proud
of them for conquering their fear into
having an awesome experience it was a
great great weather on Saturday here so
as a you never know getting into
November here in Toronto what the
weather's gonna be like but it worked
out well and so super grateful that they
took that leap of faith and conquered
their fear their number 2 i'm grateful
for a really fun weekend um on friday i
was i was hating on the weekend like I I
you know not a big fan of the weekends
always I like weekend I like weekends
when they're here but also is like the
end of my work week for the most part
still working a little bit but um we had
a really fun weekend we got ourselves
all ready for Christmas which was
awesome and got to stock gains and the
set up and bought a whole bunch of let
me show you my let me show you this is
this is what I put now on the back of
our chairs so this is like seat cover
that you put on the back so there's a
Santa Claus version and there's a frosty
version so just getting getting that
place all ready for Christmas I know
where what 49 days and when you for you
decently something like that we still
got some time but i know i think it's
specially when you have kids it's good
to get the spirit going and i wanted to
have had the tradition remember growing
up having an amazing every holiday was
amazing and i wanted to kind of give
that tradition back and have had the
place be of a house of celebration in
anyway so we got it all ready for
Christmas and I was really really really
fun weekend some grateful for that and
number 3 i'm grateful for us making
progress on things i'm grateful for
having goals and and just moving forward
on them and getting stuff done i think
it's easy for as entrepreneurs to have a
list of a thousand things that we want
to get done but sometimes taking action
on them can be hard and so I'm grateful
to have made some progress in some of my
goals in business as well
was you know even after today I've got
an electrician coming over to install
some lights there's a couple lights that
have never been installed so he's got to
run a track and he's got to do a whole
bunch of work and put him outlet in
Nina's closet so she has a light for her
makeup and all this stuff it just feels
good it feels good knowing that like
stuff is happening and that we've put
these wheels in motion and stuff is
happening and so I like making progress
and my goals that's why I think it's
important that you're spending some time
every single day 30 to 60 minutes every
day at least on your goals on your
business on what you try and get done to
get the momentum going to feel like you
have progress to feel like things are
happening because it's a it's a great
feeling and then you want to keep doing
it again so hopefully you guys are
making progress on the things in your
life so those are three things that I am
grateful for today on Monday I'm excited
to you guys have let's go to the live
chat leading this off Jay rise what are
you all grateful for I like the yellow
man the all the geology all has been an
official part of our gratitude journals
now best you pro we are one grateful for
another day of good morning believe
nation I love that thank you for that
number two grateful for the
opportunities to create inspire and
share grateful for the support of
friends and colleagues there are so many
things that can't be accomplished
without a team of people one hundred
percent if you want to go fast go alone
if you want to go far go with the team I
like that one they know number one my
teeth because they allow me to chew my
food pretty important imagine a life
without teeth I thought a lot of people
don't have teeth but I'm grateful for my
teeth I'm just trying to imagine now
trying to eat food without teeth so
thank you for that say no number two my
stove for keeping my brain in place
important and three music it's been said
before but i just find it super
important for multiple reasons i love it
first thing i do i get up go to the
washroom put music on pretty much every
day just gets me in the right mindset
for people say how are you so positive
and optimistic and energetic and happy
every day well music plays a big part of
that wake up go to the bathroom put on
some music every day you should do it to
give it a try what else zeno I might be
here from the stream but will be on my
way to the hospital once this what's the
Q&A starts hope everything's okay
there's a no gr eyes thankful for
momentum in business in dance in art and
life progress momentum I like it for
wireless devices and the clear
uncluttered freedom they give for women
and the beauty they embody and Jay has
got a new experiment to try on stream
today suggested by Evan what's the new
experiment I know what's new experiment
is 0 on the league stream on the league
stream i'm going to try a new experiment
2 we're gonna be on there and we're
leaving 3 minutes 3 minutes what else we
got uh just talk about daylight savings
we just had ours on the on the weekend
on the 5th I think in Europe was a
little bit different so figured that out
what else we got oh I just skipped what
do we got what do we got
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh Mitch I'm grateful
for fuel as it provides heat the
statewide library lending program so i
can get books from different public
libraries pretty cool and number three
food dan be good morning I'll welcomed
in you future building good morning
everyone welcome the Q hi family
grateful for friends grew before this
wonderful husband of mine and grateful
for the opportunity to mentor people on
relationships I love that sky's the
limit great rising beautiful people
happy monday i love it group of her
believe nation for helping me stay
motivated i love that thank you for
sharing that Caleb en buenos Diaz from
Miami welcome back Zeno's off to the
hospital hope everything's okay there's
a no Rishi has a lot of highs
hihihihihihi
and Santa reach the rishis in a fun mood
today and see how it goes on the on the
twitch live chat without Sarah I'm
grateful for waking up to this new day
grateful to have a gym membership great
will define a calm place in my heart
when things on the outside are not so
calm kale bien a grateful for everything
all right I love that much creeper for
the money in my bank account and coins
in my purse and hip rolls to help me
focus on more of that and hip rolls to
help me focus on more of that what that
means interesting sounds like a song it
does sound like a Sun good much is also
grateful for songs and poems that sound
good to our ears and our hearts Rishi is
good but for my internet family believe
nation I love it to Google for childhood
movies like the neverending story I
guess how that's way flies off on that
like flying dog right I'm grateful for
the present moment I love it cool guys 9
10 thank you so much for another
gratitude journal happy monday i hope
you guys have an amazing day we're gonna
head off to twitch to play a game of
League of Legends and answer your
business questions hopefully we'll see
you there if not have an amazing day
make some progress on your goals feel
the energy from this gratitude journal
and pump it into an amazing day thank
you again for watching we believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love guys I'll see you soon